aussi now sur insta Preston putin
a déjà livré plus de 1 milliard de
dollars militaire pour le crâne et plus
de 5 milliards de dollars pour
aide économique humanitaire et militaire
pour le crâne c'est une tente très
importante et nous sommes ici pour le
train dans le cours et le long terme
à la fois combien de victimes et
Monsieur Céline qui recevait aussi notre
ministre des Affaires étrangères Mélanie
Joly aujourd'hui Zelinski qui remercient
le Canada de son aide et en même temps
les ministres de l'OTAN étaient de la
Défense de l'OTAN pour ceux que vous
avez entendu madame était réuni à
Bruxelles des réunions qui s'imposent
dans ce contexte de guerre parce que à
l'ordre du jour c'était la livraison
d'armes à l'Ukraine qui avait vogue des
moments très difficiles sur le terrain
on pense à backmoat on va en parler avec
mes invités demande des avions de chasse
depuis plusieurs jours maintenant mais
pour le temps le principal besoin
intérieur les soldats pourraient bientôt
manquer de munitions et ça a pas l'air
d'être une urgence les avions de chasse
en tout cas pour
monsieur soltenberg qui a confirmé son
départ en juillet on va en parler aussi
mes invités Frédéric Meyrand professeur
de sciences politiques à l'Université de
Montréal mais en fait directeur du
département et Dominique Carel donc
titulaire d'achat en études ukrainienne
de l'Université d'Ottawa bonsoir
alors commençons par l'enjeu du moment
des ministres de la Défense qui
discutent du manque de munitions de
l'Ukraine est-ce qu'on va faire ce qu'il
faut pour que l'Ukraine n'en manque pas
d'après vous donc c'est un manque de
munitions pour l'Ukraine c'est aussi un
manque de munitions pour les pays
membres de l'OTAN donc depuis un an il y
a beaucoup de munitions donc on parle
évidemment de cartouches mais aussi
d'obus des dizaines de milliers sont
utilisés sur le théâtre d'opération
chaque jour et les Ukrainiens commencent
à manquer à un moment où ils sont un
petit peu sur la défensive sur le front
de l'Est et les stocks à l'ouest aussi
commencent à être vidé puisque dans un
premier temps ce qui a été fait c'est de
livrer ce que les occidentaux avaient
déjà dans leur stock donc là l'enjeu
c'est d'accroître la production de
manière aussi accroître la livraison de
munitions à court terme pour les
Ukrainiens
s'annonce avec une offensive de la
Russie le plus important à court terme
après les livraisons d'armes les avions
de chasse par exemple ça prend beaucoup
plus de temps pour former les pilotes
donc les lignes bougent quand même parce
qu'on a vu avec les chars d'assaut qui
ont été livrés il y a quelques semaines
c'est quelque chose d'impensable il y a
encore quelques mois donc on ne peut pas
exclure qu'il y a d'autres livraisons
d'armes mais à court terme il a été
décidé que c'était les munitions qui
étaient en jeu principal sur le théâtre
et pour vous donnera Karelle c'est
critique à ce moment-ci on dit que
backmood qui est une ville est-ce que
c'est juste un symbole mais que c'est
une ville que une ville qui pourrait
tomber aux mains des Russes la bataille
est féroce beaucoup de victimes on veut
évacuer les populations civiles à ce
moment-ci les heures qui viennent sont
cruciales pour l'Ukraine ça fait des
semaines c'est comme ça bon il y a eu la
ville de Solidar qui est tombée là ils
ont tenté une autre d'attaquer une autre
ville puis ça a été plutôt la débandade
du côté russe il se pourrait que coûte
finissent par tomber mais à quel prix on
a entendu le clip de zolenski le chaque
pouce la défendu mais il y a aussi
ajouté la Russie pour essayer d'aller
chercher ses pouces là gaspiller
énormément de munitions et pour
l'Ukraine selon zolenski c'est des
semaines qui sont donc sauvées plus tard
alors parce que lorsqu'on parle d'un
manque de munitions du côté ukrainien le
point d'interrogation c'est un certain
moment est-ce que les Russes vont
commencer à la manquer surtout les
munitions de haute précision des
missiles les obus parce qu'ils sont
capables de les produire en mesure là
ils utilisent les stocks soviétiques qui
étaient presque sans fonds
américaines
lorsque Frédéric a dit faut
approvisionner ça fait des mois que la
coalition les Américains improvisent
l'Ukraine initialement il fallait les
approvisionner en munitions de
fabrication soviétique ce qui était pas
évident ça ça venait de Bulgarie ça
venait de Tchéquie etc ça c'est ce stock
là ce sont vidés et entre temps
l'Ukraine commence à recevoir depuis des
mois là maintenant des armes des armes
de fabrication standardisée autant et
puis bon les pays de l'OTAN depuis 30
ans depuis la fin de la guerre froide
n'avait jamais prédit
qu'elle allait avoir ce type de guerre
là c'est tout de guerre là qui est
exposait avoir lieu durant la guerre
froide mais au lieu de 30 ans plus tard
alors
l'infrastructure industrielle est plus
là
c'est compliqué
et pour vous le fait que soltanmerg le
secrétaire général de le camp dit c'est
pas une les avions de chasse au fond
c'est pas sur notre Adam c'est pas ça le
plus urgent mais est-ce que ils vont
finir par répondre quelque chose il est
probable qu'on finisse par y arriver
mais encore une fois il faut se replacer
il y a bientôt un an on aurait pas
imaginé que les systèmes d'armement qui
sont actuellement livrés à l'Ukraine
pourraient l'être un jour on parle de
système de défense anti-aérienne on
parle de char d'assaut très sophistiqués
et donc il est possible qu'on en arrive
aux avions de chasse il y a toujours
cette crainte qui demeure depuis un an
qui de savoir mais ses avions de chasse
s'ils allaient dans le l'espace aérien
russe que ça signifierait pour la
poursuite de la guerre mais au-delà de
ça l'argument qui est utilisé par le
secrétaire général Stoltenberg et par
d'autres c'est que former des pilotes à
l'usage d'avion de chasse de l'Ouest ça
prendrait un an et donc ce ne serait pas
utile à court terme sur sur le terrain
d'informer oui mais ça prend du temps
quand même donc ce sera pas utilisable
dans un mois en même temps donc le
rapport de force est-il en train de
changer sur le terrain le rapport de
force je pense que on va avoir une très
très bonne idée en mars et avril lorsque
l'Ukraine va lancer sa contre-offensive
bon là on annonce que la Russie va être
capable de faire une contre-offensive ça
reste à voir parce que pour la maman ils
ont beau pilonné barmotte etc c'est
toujours la même technique
c'est à dire à l'artillerie pousse par
pouce un coup humain
énorme et puis les nouveaux soldats là
la fameuse mobilisation sont peu c'est
pas les les troupes d'élite qui déjà ont
été dévastés il y a un an il y a 6 mois
alors ça reste à voir si la Russie à
cette capacité là mais la l'Ukraine
pourrait l'avoir dans en mars et avril
et là c'est là on va voir s'il y a
vraiment un nouveau rapport de force qui
s'établit juste un petit mot sur les
avions évidemment cette dynamique là
change beaucoup parce que l'argument a
ça va prendre du temps les former
c'était la même argument pour les temps
et puis finalement on vous les donne les
chars ou les chats
c'est que l'autre danger c'est que vous
savez il y a les fameuses vagues
d'attaque à coup de drone puis de
missiles contre les infrastructures
énergétiques il y en a eu une encore il
y a quelques jours la crainte c'est
l'Ukraine commence à manquer de missile
anti-aérien puis si l'Ukraine se
retrouve dans cette situation là là elle
est vulnérable à une attaque on des
avions russes les avions russes et les
fourniraient ces armes là parce que
c'est quoi les quelques jours il y avait
eu 70 missiles the linskids on en a
battu
61 donc il y en a 9 qui ont finalement
tué des gens
qui ont été utilisés donc par les
ukrainiens et puis les stocks sont pas
encore une fois c'est des missiles
soviétiques là de fabrication soviétique
parce que les systèmes qui ont été
promis sont pas encore opérationnels et
la visite de madame Joly avec zelins on
en a pas entendu parler
c'est important cette rencontre là pour
vous je pense que c'est conforme ce qui
a été la politique du Canada depuis un
an c'est-à-dire un affichage très fort
de la solidarité canadienne qui a
l'évidence est appréciée qui est suivi
quand même d'un soutien logistique la
ministre de la Défense le rappeler mais
un soutien logistique qui est à la
hauteur des capacités canadiennes qui
elles-mêmes sont faibles par rapport à
tous les autres pays membres de l'OTAN
pour différentes raisons historiques
donc ça reste quand même
symbolique
au Canada mais comme monsieur soltenberg
a annoncé pas confirmer son départ pour
juillet à la fin de son mandat
Christophe Freeland est-elle une
candidate intéressante pour le temps moi
je pense qu'elle est une candidate
intéressante parce que beaucoup de
rumeurs de couloirs disent il faudrait
que la prochaine secrétaire général soit
une femme il y a quelques candidates sur
les rangs une des candidates c'était la
présidente de la Commission européenne
pour cela vanderline mais qui ne pourra
pas être candidate cette fois-ci parce
que c'est trop tôt il y a des candidates
comme la première ministre de l'Estonie
qui sont sur les reins qui sont
effectivement ce qu'on dit c'est
normalement ce poste bien à un européen
ou une Européenne la question c'est de
savoir le Canada est-il un pays européen
après il n'est pas américain donc dans
ce sens-là elle a des chances elle a
aussi une connaissance
inégalée de l'Ukraine pas seulement
parce qu'elle est descendance
ukrainienne c'est parce que le travail
est là à ses débuts comme journaliste
et puis ça la mettrait je pense que la
démontrer tout de même qu'à un certain
flair politique depuis qu'elle est en
poste l'an 2015 bon c'était au niveau
intérieur au niveau canadien mais dans
le contexte d'une guerre sans précédent
contre
les crèmes ça pourrait être une
candidate effectivement c'est unique
pour dire un instant Frédéric il y a un
an on aurait pas pu imaginer que les
munitions qui sont fournies à l'Ukraine
serait fournie mais on pensait pas
célébrer mais souligner arriver au
premier anniversaire de cette guerre-là
êtes-vous
concerner inquiet de cet adversaire là
que ça vient la semaine prochaine moi je
pense qu'on a su assez rapidement que la
guerre serait très longue et à l'heure
actuelle tout pense tout laisse à croire
qu'elle va continuer à être longue
évidemment la surprise ça a quand même
été la résistance exceptionnelle de
l'Ukraine mais peu de gens pensaient que
la guerre ne durerait que quelques
semaines je crois c'est la résistance
mais c'est aussi la résistance et les
contre-fensives
au mois d'août au mois de septembre
novembre les gains à 4 arquifs personnes
et ça c'est en lien direct avec les
lignes rouges qui tombent on va vous
donner des chars les avions vont suivre
c'est assez clair je peux pas prédire
mais c'est dans la dynamique qui
éventuellement les Ukrainiens vont avoir
tous les moyens justement pour essayer
de reprendre leur territoire parce que
ça changerait la géopolitique mondiale
ça c'est l'autre chose je pense qu'on
avait mal anticipé aujourd'hui
les questions commencent quand on veut
répondre à une question géopolitique on
commence par depuis le 24 février 2022
donc dans ce sens-là l'impact est majeur
était mobilisé c'est de répéter que
c'est la guerre c'est c'est notre guerre
à nous aussi de nos démocraties tout ça
ça
la première ministre
d'orientation néo-fasciste mélonie en
Italie on aurait pu penser à tout va
basculer on lui a demandé pourquoi vous
continuez depuis la guerre c'est parce
que c'est une guerre d'agression
une garde agression effectivement c'est
une garde agression puisse il y a encore
ce consensus ça parle le Premier
ministre hongrois là qui qui tient après
un an qui est assez qui est assez fort
c'est
elle
ça reste l'ambition de Poutine d'essayer
de diviser cette coalition politique
mais politiquement la condition entre
forte savoir si les Ukrainiens sur le
terrain sont vraiment capables de
reprendre rapidement et la Turquie est
ailleurs là
beaucoup de formes de coopération pour
des raisons souvent de politique interne
aussi parce qu'il veut mais en ce moment
je pense que son rôle de médiation va
être mis en mode mineur pour plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois merci Frédéric
merci de mecs bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]